are we gonna see any females
return you're just getting at lexi
because she's been trending since last
week on twitter
i can reveal that i just read a script
like literally in the past two weeks
that completely floored me
i had no idea and it's wild
more shocking than patrick's return
or as shocking to me it was more
shocking
before we kind of get started i mean we
are living in crazy times right now
just how are you kind of doing with
everything i'm doing good
i gave birth during the pandemic i love
a
almost warm-up sun and i have a
three-year-old that you know is
he's kind of sick of lockdown but we're
all being safe
and you know we're just thankful that
we're all healthy still right now
how is hayden adjusting to being a big
sister i think right now it's still like
world of hayden is how she's adjusting i
mean i think she thinks she's like oh
like we've got another cute puppy kind
of like situation
she's actually so cute and then it's
like okay now everybody watch me i'm
gonna sing elsa
so um she's adjusted really well she
thinks he's very very cute
but he's still sort of a baby like blob
right now so let's see what happens when
he starts like stealing her toys
right right right what was it like i
mean
to give birth amid everything was it
scary at all
um it was scary to give birth during
everything it really was
um i tried not to think about it but
things were just different
my husband couldn't come to any of my
ultrasounds you have to wear a mask and
you have to wear a mosque in labor so i
was
you know in labor in a mosque for like
over 15 hours which was like pretty
daunting
it makes an already difficult situation
that much
more difficult it definitely does um
i'm someone that likes to have all the
birthday drugs that's what i call them
to make you feel more comfortable so
once i
you know got my epidural and everything
like that i kind of relaxed enough to
sort of forget about the mask to be
honest but it was daunting
no visitors you know none of that
happening i mean was your family was
your husband
bummed not to be able to be in the
delivery room well my husband could be
in the delivery room thank god but no
other
no other person could come visit or be
with you
and none of our family members have
actually met
are four months old and they're not
going to for christmas either because
they're not coming for christmas this
year
we can't the truth are you guys
now getting any sleep at least or how is
it no never
there was no sleep to begin with i mean
no we're not really getting any sleep
but i think
that there's a point as new parents to
more parents to a baby one on new
parents or parents or child where you're
just sort of running on that parent
adrenaline
and then you crash out at the end of the
night and that sort of you know
that's sort of what we're doing is it
hard now with you being back
to work to be dealing with that and all
the protocols that are on set and then
to come home and you wanna i'm sure make
sure that your family is safe
yeah we can i mean i definitely in a
weird way
in a weird strange way i actually feel
safe even though i'm working amongst a
lot more people before i was just
completely in my own bubble
yeah everyone gets tested three times a
week so there's that constant
reassurance that you're testing negative
um and you know when i come home i strip
off my clothes i take a shower before i
hug the kids and kind of do stuff like
that
it's difficult though it definitely is
difficult and it's a lot of trust that
goes into
trusting those people around you that
you're working with every day
well let's talk about the show because
there's so much going on
i want to start with joe and jackson
okay
what was your reaction when you first
heard about
this storyline well i
first heard about it um right before we
actually shut down
and then the storyline got tweaked just
a little bit to be
a covered sex pod is what i'm calling it
yeah but i
was really shocked but um
excited at the same time first off i do
love working with jesse williams we
always have ask for scenes together
because we have a lot of fun um
we have a lot of fun between takes
together it's just really we enjoy it
um so i was excited to do the scenes but
i was also excited to see a single
joe this season and and to see
what she looks like as a woman out there
in the world
dating sure do you think
she is still in love with
career or part of her will always be
that's a really interesting question i
think
at this point i don't think she's in
love with him anymore
that's that would be my guess is that
she's not in love with him anymore
but that she was in love with
the life they had and the idea of the
future they had together
and i think that might be more painful
to let go of for her
sure well i think it's not the person
anymore i think it's what they had
i mean with jackson she did try
to hook up with him initially and it
didn't work out i think because she was
kind of
trying to figure out what is single joe
like yeah
like sam's currently yeah i think that
even if you're not in love with someone
like that first
kiss of kissing somebody octave kiss on
for so long is so strange and jarring
probably brings up a bunch of stuff
that's what i felt like she was feeling
and i think that it was just a lot of
feelings at once
and then she was ready what do you think
it was about
that second time i mean you said all of
a sudden she was ready do you think
anything shifted
emotionally for her do you think she
gave herself a pep talk in a way
i think that she wasn't drinking vodka
from
a bottle which felt i think
there was no pressure i think that she
put pressure on herself
and there wasn't any and um and
sometimes i
and it wasn't a date situation
whatsoever there wasn't like you know
the jackson playing kenny g right yeah
um so i think that exactly so i think
with like the pressure off
she realized in that moment like oh
actually i'm ready
both of them said they do not want a
relationship
this is just a quarantine hookup
do you believe that yes and no i mean i
don't believe it because it's grey's
anatomy and like
you know this is what happens but
playing her right
now i believe that she believes it
that's what i think and right now that
is what is happening
in our season but we haven't i haven't
seen
that's half of the season i haven't read
so it can change
what would it look like if they were to
enter into a
relationship um you know what i actually
think that they would be a really
fun couple i think that they would have
that like banter back and forth of sort
of making fun of each other which you
will see
in the episode we're about to shoot
right now actually we're shooting next
week
you kind of see that happening between
them already so i think that they would
be that like very jokey couple with each
other
and hopefully i also think that because
they've had
things have already happened between
them that are very intimate and
vulnerable i think hopefully that they
would
be open with talking about their
feelings because
they already had a conversation that was
pretty awkward to have at the door where
he was like i'm not ready and she
explained why and she said the same
thing and explained why too
would you like it to turn more serious
i have mixed opinions on it
yes because i love working with jessie
and yes because i think
jack's navy is a good guy but i also
want to see her play the field a little
bit
ah do you think she has her eye on any
other
i don't think there is anybody else it's
covered and there's no options um
but i would like to sort of see more of
what single joe
is like okay i was gonna ask you
i mean she was in such a dark place
after karev left and i feel like last
season in general she was in a pretty
dark place
yeah do you think now is kind of the
start of
a new beginning a new chapter for
joe and like there's light at the end of
the tunnel for her i definitely do
i definitely do and it's interesting you
say that because i think that
it's more i'm going to be very cryptic
about it because i can't spoil anything
but there are a lot of elements of her
life that she's sort of reassessing this
season
and thinking does this make me happy
does this not make me happy
what can i do to change it
is she questioning her career path
maybe you'll have to watch i will not
say anything else
but there are other things she she kind
of questions and i think
you know joan coven you have a lot of
time to sit and think
i think she has a lot of time to sit and
think and sort of
really reassess everything something
else that
has been amazing to watch is the return
of some of our favorite
beloved characters
patrick dempsey tr knight we do know
that patrick is going to appear in more
episodes
yes what should we expect
the truth is i have no idea and the
reason i have no idea
is because we are not given those scenes
in our scripts
and the crew when they go to the beach
actually is not given the scenes they
can't even hear what they're saying
that's how secret these scenes are so a
lot of times
even when crew members are there
shooting it um
like hair and makeup and stuff i'll say
oh how'd it go what are they talking
about
we knew of people that were coming back
but we don't know
how it ends what the context is any of
that stuff so we're watching with you
guys when we see it
do you think i know you don't know but
is there a world in which there
is a mare dare kiss
in the future okay so i truly don't know
my camilla theory that if they kiss
does that mean that she's choosing that
world oh and then we don't really get
her back
and then we might not get her back but i
don't know i mean that's like i have so
many theories on it
because we don't even really know what
it is is she dreaming is it purgatory
like what i don't know what the beach
really is right
um and i think it's i think it's left up
to us to interpret
the way we want it to for that exact
reason but i worry
does she not get close like why can't
she get close
what is your biggest theory about what
the beach signifies
my theory about the beach is that it's
not a dream
my theory is that she's teetering
between
both worlds the world of like the george
conversation
has really happened like spiritually
happened
to me it like really happened and
derek's really speaking to her and it's
not just a dream she keeps happening it
kind of happens when she slips in and
out of consciousness
none of us have been briefed as to what
it really means and i think that we're
waiting
as well as you know with the audience to
see what it means i do want to know who
else
is coming back because there's been lots
of rumors about that
can you tell me how many other people
are coming back it's probably the
biggest secret of our season
i mean it's a massive secret is there
anyone
whose return has shocked you more than
patrick dempsey's
no that was the biggest patrick
returning is like
to me as a fan watching was like it
can't
be beat that's how i feel okay um
because i loved maradera together are we
gonna see any
females return you're just getting at
lexi because she's been trending since
last week on twitter right
i mean i do think lexi and mark people
really want them to come back
i don't know if they're a perspective i
mean i do know but i'm not gonna tell
you i'm not gonna say yes or no either
way okay
meredith is entering a covid
trial thanks to richard's decision
what should we expect from this
storyline moving forward
so this is it's hard because
we it's a really weird season for us
this is the first season that we don't
know
it's actually a conversation that
happens on set all the time i was on set
the other day and we're like what do you
think is going to happen
and we truly don't know so usually i'd
be able to tease
kind of something about that question
but this
is the first season that i have no idea
i don't know what's going to happen to
meredith gray i really do not
that makes me worried makes me worried
too
do you do you think i mean she has said
that they've thought about
how the show could potentially end yeah
you think because all these people are
coming back
and they are being so secretive that
this could be the last season
i think listen i think that every season
could be the last season i think that
i've always felt that because we're on
the air for 17 seasons so i'm like this
will be the last season
like i mean and then we keep going on
and the fans keep watching and showing
up
what do you guys say when you talk about
it on set like are there rumblings of do
we think this show was ending
but the rumblings are always like we
can't end right like surely we have like
there's no way because every single
season
our the story lines just blow us away
and so
i think we always feel like there's so
much more story that we could always
tell
but you know there is definitely an
element of
wanting to i'm sure go out on top and
you know it's still the number one show
and the fans still adore it
i think there's so much more joe's story
to tell you know one day i think that it
would
i want her at some point you know to
have her family that she wants i want
her to find love again
i want her to be a bad doctor i mean
there's so many things
yeah i want for her do you think if
ellen leaves the show there is a show
without
ellen pompeo that's a good question i
i have always thought because shonda has
said that
you know the show goes with ellen like
when they're done they're done
and so i think that that's just the way
i've personally always pictured it
okay well i hope that she's not ready to
leave
pom karasik looks to be in
bad condition we see him sort of
wrapped up in a blanket profusely
what can you reveal about his fate
is their recovery something that we
should hope for
well um if anyone's going to survive
it's going to be tom classic isn't it
i mean he is he's unclear
i i know i mean again like my answer
unfortunately is really similar that in
our scripts that was
we're reading right now he's still sick
so i don't know
where that's going um and i hadn't you
know it's interesting because
i watched the show live on thursday and
this is the first time i'm seeing it too
and it was very jarring you know it's
written that he's like shaking and
shipping but that image of him was
really jarring to me
to see um so i don't know
i feel like it's tom's classic he's
gonna
of course beat it but we haven't read
the script since the honest answer
thinking ahead you guys are obviously
still shooting
are there more shocking moments
tearful moments ahead what can you
reveal about what's to come
okay so i can reveal
that i just read a script
like literally in the past two weeks
that completely floored me
i had no idea and it's wild
this season is just like honestly this
season just like turns everything on
their head in fact i didn't even believe
it
i was like that's not real and i was
like texting people and then
it's a crazy season more shocking than
patrick's return
or as shocking in a diff
um to me it was more shocking
oh yeah but i mean to somebody else it
might not be but to me i just
really did not see it coming yeah do any
other doctors
contract coven 19 i can say obviously
it's an extremely contagious disease and
they're working
on the front lines so it's definitely
possible that any one of us can
absolutely does joe get it i can't say
what are the chances karev could return
can we please not have another
ex-husband for joe
show up this poor girl
i just feel like how many are there
i mean do you think
it would help to give her closure though
if he did come back for some
reason i think the reality is for a lot
of people is that they don't get that
moment when they like
are speaking to their ex so i think it's
real to show that sometimes you have to
move on
without having the sit-down conversation
and so i think that she is she talks
about being in therapy i actually
like that she's able to work through it
it doesn't depend
on whether he picks up the phone and
calls her and wants to discuss it
i think it's like a very empowering
storyline for her
you